santé ça pue oui sinon qu en fait lâché
un nouveau concept je demande aux gens
dans la rue s'ils connaissent des
blagues un peu une avoir un peu
stigmatisant coller sur les gros vas-y
c'est quoi un rookie travail à la croix
rouge
vas-y un roue de secours n'ont pas pu
transatlantique de plaques sont leurs
couleurs l'a fait sur l'humain on a fait
sur les brevets sont des juifs
voilà pas très chaude et j'ai fait les
dents c'est quoi ta blague sur les roues
ouais c'était quoi la blague sur les
routes qu'on appelle un rookie a réussi
six mois le rôle de parti ruth fortune
chez lui l'a plaquée or qu'elle est pas
méchante non non non non il va me casser
la gueule c'est quand le sport préféré
des robots vas-y tu vois pas les sports
hippiques
pourquoi as tu pu te vois tu respectes à
maison hippiques tour
thomas mich et c'est l'humour un
tranquille tu me manques du cliché rien
volé j'ai bien roulé je serais tu peux
les blacks un petit peu stigmatisant et
d'un chrétien
ouais une salle où on entend des
musulmans les juifs les chrétiens
j'ai un bon continuer l'histoire de
balasy raconte ce fait en fait
l'histoire c'est que les juifs les
chrétiens les arabes dans six mois
[Applaudissements]